ما المعطيات التي توفرت في هذا الصدد
والمعلومات التي استطعتم الحصول عليها
فيما يتعلق بالضربه الرابعه الامريكيه
لمواقع يسيطر عليها الحوثيون في
اليمن نعم محمد بالتاكيد هذا اول تاكيد
رسمي من قبل مسؤول امريكي في وزاره الدفاع
او مسؤول دفاعي امريكي للجزيره في افاده
للجزيره بان هذه الضربه الرابعه قد حدثت
وحدد للجزيره في تصريحاته الخاصه للجزيره
او في افادته الخاصه للجزيره ردا على سؤال
للزميل فادي منصور بان هذه الضربه قد وجهت
عند الثانيه فجرا تقريبا بتوقيت العاصمه
اليمنيه صنعاء هذه اول افاده رسميه من
جانب مصادر دفاعيه رسميه امريكيه لايه
وسيله اعلام حول هذه الضربه بعد ما نقلتها
شبكه سي بي اس الامريكيه عن مسؤولين
امريكيين هذا ايضا تاكيد رسمي للجزيره
وبالتالي تاكدنا الان بشكل لا يقبل الشك
بان هذه ضربه رابعه وجهت فجر اليوم
وبالتالي هذا يعزز محمد كما اشرنا في
مداخله سابقه بان الاربعاء الذي ما زلنا
نحن فيه الان في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كان يوما حافلا شهد تصنيف جماعه
الحوثي من قبل اداره بايدن كجماعه ارهابيه
مره اخرى وشهد ايضا هذا الرد الامريكي على
ما تعتبره الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تهديدا لسفن الامريكيه وتهديدا للملاحه
الدوليه نحن الان في مرحله يمكن ان نصفها
بانها مرحله تصعيد وتصعيد مضاد وربما هي
مرحله تصعيد محسوب مقابل تصعيد محسوب ايضا
ف جماعه الحوثي تستهدف الان السفن
التجاريه الامريكيه بعدما كانت تستهدف فقط
السفن المتجهه الى اسرائيل او السفن
الاسرائيليه الان تستهدف السفن التجاريه
الامريكيه هل يمكن ان تكون المرحله
المقبله استهداف سفن عسكريه امريكيه ام لا
ربما هذا يمكن ان تسفر عنه الايام المقبله
حسب خطوات التصعيد من الجانب الامريكي
وايضا التصعيد المضاد من جانب الحوثيين
وحسب ايضا القدرات الحوثيه العسكريه
الحوثيه فالمسؤولون الامريكيون محمد
يتحدثون انهم لا يزالون في مرحله تقييييم
اثر الضربات الامريكيه على الاراضي
اليمنيه والاثر الذي الحقته بقدرات
الحوثيين العسكريم